in the Far East of Myanmar is a de facto
independent territory it's run by the
country's largest rebel army which
unilaterally declared it wire state it's
largely cut off from the outside world
in particular the rest of Myanmar right
now why is still a wild frontier people
who live here have ID cuts but only for
this state we can travel outside of here
the United wire state army controls two
areas on the borders with Thailand and
China the state is run under a one-party
communist system it's heavily reliant on
Chinese support in the form of trade
investment and in the near future thanks
to a new casino possibly tourism when I
first moved here there was only jungle
everywhere but now it's more developed
in the past it was very poor and far
behind but it's getting better the wire
signed a bilateral ceasefire deal with
the Myanmar army in 1989 and haven't
been directly involved in any
significant fighting since now largely
left to run their own affairs and still
maintain a well organized and well
resourced fighting force of up to 30,000
now about coming under pressure to join
the government's nationwide ceasefire
agreement which like many other ethnic
armies now refusing to do they say
they're not prepared to meet one of the
key conditions of that deal which is for
their soldiers to lay down their weapons
and join the Myanmar military the wire
are also fiercely protective of their
income streams like Jade mining and the
illegal wildlife trade many products
like Tiger and beer teeth are sold
openly in the state capital Hong Kong
the United wire State Army is also
thought to be one of the region's
largest manufacturers of illegal drugs a
business it says it's no longer in but
there are many who believe those who run
this area are still stuck in the past
and until they open up life will not
improve oh yeah I mean I want war to
continue to develop I want to see more
people move through here which will
improve trade and business in the past
two or three years it's been very bad I
can't make or sell much
while state serves as a reminder of how
fragmented Myanmar is while this area
may be at peace for now it's the people
that continue to pay the price of civil
war through isolation and a lack of
developments Wayne hey al-jazeera